- Bonjour monsieur Lemoine!
Dre Saint-Cyr. On va commencer
les manoeuvres. EPI 1 mg x 3
J'ai besoin des signes vitaux!
- On a de mander un ordre
de la cour...
- On va parler de STAT,
une nouvelle quotidienne.
Vous incarnez Emmanuelle
Saint-Cyr, urgentoe.e.e.
C'est tout un défi.
120 épisodes, à peu près
150 jours de tournage.
Pourquoi avoir accepté
ce défi-là?
SUZANNE CLÉMENT, actrice
- Je penueueue, moi, j'aime
beaucoup les défis, dans la vie,
j'en ai fait plus d'un.
L'année passée, j'avais fait
une scène de bataille
dans d d douche en prison,
dans un tournage en France, nue.
C'est pas pour exciter personne,
là, parce que c'est pas ça, là,
mais c'est le niveau
d'intensité, d'exigence.
Je me disais : Mais pourquoi?
Pourquoi j'ai dit oui à ça?
Qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
dans ma tête? Et donc,
mais c'est sûr qu'une fois que
tu le fais puis que tu réussis
à le faire puis que tu trouves
l'énigme dans ta tête de comment
je vais réussir à faire ça,
cette chose-là, ça devient
addictif aussi, puis c'est ça
qui nous amène plus  a a aussi,
évidemment, puis qui nous fait
découvrir des zones de nous-
mêmes qu'on connaissait pas.
Donc, STAT, ça fait partie
de ça. Le niveau de... de
vitesse de travail, il faut bien
le dire, la quantité de textes
à apprendre.
Maria!
Où est ma fille?
- Vous parlez de défi, mais un
des grands défis dans votre vie,
ça a été de passer près
0 0 0 ans en France à jouer
sur des plateaux européens.
- Ouais.
- Vous avez travaillé pour
des séries comme Versailles,
La Forêt, La Bulle, Vampires,
Dégegeges... ouf!
- Ouais. Ouais, j'ai pas chômé.
- C'est quand même... hein?
OuOuOui, oui.
- Semble-t-il que c'est le décès
de votre père qui vous a ramenée
à Montréal d'une certaine façon.
- Oui. Oui, oui, oui, c'était
dur. Là, c'était vraiment dur
de partir. Et puis, j'ai...
Je suis revenue parce que
je voulais aussi m'occuper
de ma mère, puis être proche
de ma soeur puis de ma famille.
Puis, en fait,
ça fait sens complètement.
Ça a été comme une révélation.
Fait que c'est ça...
- Une révélation?
- Un petit peu. C'est comme
quelque chose que je savais.
C'était sous-jacent en moi, là,
que j'avais le désir peut-être
de revenir, mais...
C'est... Mon père m'a fait ce
cadeau-là, d'une certaine façon.
ouais, de vraiment faire le pas,
puis de faire : Ah! En fait,
je suis très bien,
de retour à Montréal.
- Comment ça s'est fait?
Parce que vous êtes un modèle
pour d'autres comédiens,
comédiennes du Québec qui
voudraient percer en France.
- Bien... c'flflflatteur.
Bien, écoute, c'est surtout
les films de Xavier, là.
C'est vraiment Xavier qui est...
Xavier Dolan. C'est grâce à lui.
Et c'est à cause de
Laurence Anyways...
- Mommy.
- On est allés à Cannes.
Puis Mommy après. C'est à partir
de Laurence Anyways que, là,
les agents m'ont... rararance,
m'ont dit qu'il y avait...
il y a un intérêt.
T'as-tu déjà eu peur quand
tu sors de chez vous puis qu'il
se fasse tabasser dans la rue
puis qu'il te reviennes pas
en un morceau?
Ça tombait bien dans ma vie.
J'avaivivivie de vivre
cette grande aventure-là.
Puis Mommy, bien oui.
Mommy a été encore un autre...
Il a été très, très, très
apprécié. Puis il l'est encore,
vivivier. Fait que, par la bande
aussi, ses acteurs le sont.
- Ou c c c'est sûr que Mommy,
Laurence Anyways ont vraiment
eu un rôle fondamental dans
votre carrière. Mais Les hauts
et les bas de Sophie Paquin,
cette série-là aussi a eu
un impact profond sur votre
carrière parce que vous avez
récolté 2 Gémeaux. Et là,
tout s'est mis vraiment...
Le jeu s'est ouvert.
Il y avait eu des grands
films avant, mais...
- C'est vrai, mais...
- Ouais, avec le recul,
peut-être?
- Oui, c'est drôle parce qu'on
en reparlait justement avec
des amis en bas, à quel point
on a eu une période heureuse
et drôle. On a tellement ri
à faire cette série.
Jel'l'l'annonce officiellement,
Robert Paquin...
j'ai besoin d'un signe!
(miaulement)
Mais oui, en fait, à ce moment-
là, je me rappelle que
je m'étais dit.. j'avais envie
de le faire. Je m'étais vraiment
fait coacher aussi pour faire
Sophie, puis... Puis, c'était
une coche de : je prends en
ch c c cette affaire-là
d'être aussi, bon... c'est ton
personnage qui est dans le titre
de la série. Ça dit quelque
chose aussi, ça, ce que que t'es
prête à porter sur tes épaules.
Fait que, oui, çététété
une série super importante.
- Quelle aventure
extraordinaire!
Je boucle la boucle avec
la quotidienne STAT...
- Oui!
- ... dédédébute très bientôt,
le 12 septembre. Vous dites :
"J'ai un peu peur, mais
je carbure à l'adrénaline."
- Oui.
- Vous faites de la course
à pied.
- Oui!
- Comment ça se vit ce besoin
d'adrénaline-là,
Suzanne Clément?
- C'est intéressant parce que,
cette semaine, je me disais ça,
je me disais : Ah! tabarnouche!
Dans la durée, c'est correct.
Je le vois que je suis correcte
dans la durée, mais vous sss
un coureur de fond,
donc je pense que vous pouvez
comprendre, il y a vraiment
quelque chose dans l'endurance,
dans la... puis dans
la répétition, parce que
c'est une vraie discipline,
c'est une méditation aussi
qui fait que... c'est ça,
ça répond à ce projet-là.
aiaiai bien hâte de voir STAT!
Merci beaucoup, Suzanne Clément.
- Merci à vous!
- Merci!
- Après, on va loyoyoyer
au scan. Sophia, est-ce que tu
peux appeler le bloc opératoire?
- Oui. Je m'en occup